Have you had a chance to look over the handout for my presentation?
Yes, Mark.
And I have some questions about the content.
Really?
Do you think I need to adjust the content of the presentation?
A little.
For instance, I don't think the example you give in the introduction is really relevant...
...and the complexity of the last two sections of the presentation...
...may be too much to explain in the allotted time for this presentation.
I guess I have a lot more work to do on the structure of the whole presentation.
Maybe after you work on it more, you can practice in front of me.
Great!
You can tell me if I use good eye contact or have distracting mannerisms.